tudo bem com vocês
talvez hoje eu seja a única pessoa que
não vai usar slides não sei acho vai
usar
eu sou a única pessoa que não vai usar
lights porque o que eu tenho pra falar
pra vocês hoje aqui é mais uma conversa
é e eu gostaria e transmitir um pouco da
emoção que eu tive então começa a
conversa com vocês hoje falando falando
da história de um cidadão qualquer
tá que vivia uma vida normal como todo
mundo tinha seus sonhos tinha sua rotina
tinha seus objetivos e um dia ele
decidiu sair de casa mudou pra outro
lugar
fui fazer faculdade e queria viver houve
uma vida diferente e que as pessoas que
estavam no meio dele naquele tempo e viu
sair de casa foi cursar uma faculdade em
que estudava em período integral errado
pra caramba
a prova de cálculo e calcula um carro do
estábulo mérico álgebra era uma loucura
aquilo que o cara tava vivendo uma coisa
lá que ele estava desesperado no meio
daquele furacão ele não conseguia
trabalhar e era sustentado pelos pais
ele vivia um perrengue porque cara ao
mesmo tempo que ele era sustentado pelos
pais
esse cara não conseguia trabalhar não
consiga trazer dinheiro e os pais
estavam em uma situação que não era lá
muito legal
enfim era um furacão a vida do cara o
cara tava vivendo uma coisa que ele
achava que levar ele pra algum lugar que
ele queria que era um lugar que ele
sonhava num determinado dia e esse cara
estava estudando com uma prova e quando
ele se deu conta já era madrugada duas e
meia da manhã naquela cidade o cara
pensou pouco e agora é que eu vou comer
no jantar ainda estava só com almoço
estou estudando sem parar
e aí pessoal bom não tenho de pedir
comida ou em casa né beleza o cara
levantou do computador ou na cozinha
abre a geladeira
portugal falhou na estante do que
encontrou na comida naquele apartamento
onde ele morava
ele dividia com dois amigos foi um saco
de arroz
naquela noite esse cara comeu arroz sem
sal
era tudo que tinha pra comer aquela
noite sentado num sofá da sala depois de
comer arroz rumoroso sem sal sem quase
nada parecido por esse cara começou a
pensar que estou fazendo a minha vida e
só que vai me levar pra onde eu quero tá
valendo a pena passar por isso aqui tudo
para chegar onde eu quero isso tô
caminhando pra onde eu quero para o meu
sonho de verdade
naquela noite ele decidiu tomar uma
decisão
no dia seguinte acordou ele pegou o
telefone e ligou para casa falou o pai
mãe tô voltando
vou mudar minha vida vou fazer tudo
diferente
vou começar a trabalhar eu vou me
sustentar vocês não vão ter que se
preocupar comigo eu vou transferir minha
faculdade pra outro lugar fazer uma
faculdade noite estudar e tal
e esse cara foi lá e fez vestibular de
novo foi aprovado no vestibular
entrou num curso diferente mas quero na
mesma área período noturno arrumou
emprego começou a trabalhar passou
perrengue pra caramba se lascou pra
caramba esse cara chegou lá
ele tinha um sonho naquele momento o
sucesso daquele cara era se sustentar
para ele o sucesso era não depender de
ninguém
hoje esse cara chegou muito longe muito
além de onde ele estava e ele quer
chegar muito mais
hoje esse cara consegue pagar suas
contas esse cara se sustenta
hoje esse cara investidor hoje esse cara
é trader autônomo e opera bolsas aqui no
brasil estados unidos no mercado de
moedas
hoje esse cara é um dos 850 analista de
valores mobiliários que existem no país
e hoje a partir das 19 horas à espera
também explica que impede sim eu passei
por tudo isso e durante essa caminhada
toda que eu tive passando perrengue
lazcano
eu sempre levei comigo uma frase
de um cara que muita gente deve conhecer
que o estudantil é esse cara tem uma
frase que é muito boa e que foi como um
mantra na minha vida que diz o seguinte
o sucesso é você e de fracasso em
fracasso sem perder o entusiasmo
isso é o sucesso sucesso uma sucessão se
é uma sucessão é uma seqüência é uma
seqüência de coisas que ainda não teve
sucesso foram fracassos e para você
chegar nesse sucesso você tem que
fracassar várias e várias vezes sem
perder o entusiasmo e aí quando você
chega lá no final você tem o seu sucesso
e aí eu pergunto o que é o sucesso para
você hoje
qual é o seu sucesso hoje hoje qual é o
seu sucesso porque como eu falei naquela
época o meu sucesso para me sustentar e
não consegui ver minha vida sem depender
de ninguém né aquele era meu sucesso
eu pergunto mais o que você fez hoje
para alcançar esse sucesso
talvez hoje vocês estejam respondendo
por mim aqui estou participando no ped
programa idéia prendendo coisa nova pra
interagindo na verdade mas eu não teria
sabido ponto em que trabalhei e inteiro
a chegar em casa que alugava a casa
limpa cachorro para banho né
muita coisa a fazer o mar estava
enchendo o saco só ficava em um sofá
vendo futebol né beleza mas aí o que
você fez por seu sucesso mas aí rocha é
muito ruim velho vou ter q que despender
tempo gastar tempo além do que eu tenho
uma rotina cansativa e tal e aí eu
pergunto pra você
se você fosse morar em outro mundo outro
planeta você pudesse levar cinco coisas
deste mundo pra esse planeta se elevaria
sua rotina se elevaria seu trabalho se
elevaria sua obrigação de limpar a casa
e levar o cachorro você tem que dar
banho em cachorro sim é o modelo da
banda cachorro ela o cachorro é legal
todo mundo gosta né
quais são as coisas que você levaria se
elevaria sua rotina sem emprego as
coisas com as quais você gastar sua
energia você levaria toda sal todas as
suas coisas
perguntem o que acontece é que a grande
maioria das pessoas
acaba não fazendo pra elas mesmo o que é
importante
ou seja elas gastam energia com coisas
que não estão na lista
poxa se a sua rotina não está na sua
lista seu emprego não está na sua lista
porque você gastar sua energia você
gasta a sua vida o seu tempo com coisas
que não estão nessa lista
a grande maioria das pessoas gastar
muito tempo com coisas que não são
relevantes não são importantes de
verdade e isso a gente faz sem perceber
a galera se vocês olharem no youtube
quanto tempo vocês passam por dia no
youtube vocês vão se surpreender
eu fui pego por isso uma vez eu parei
pra pensar cada passo muito tempo aqui
ver no vídeo fla v
dá pra ver isso a naná sua conta está a
quatro horas por dia o passamento falei
caraca
como assim quatro horas cara eu não li
nem dez páginas de um livro que eu
queria ler que é importante pra mim
então gastem tempo com que é importante
pra vocês tá o resto acaba sendo
desculpa galera a mas a gente tem que
fazer todo mundo tem casa todo mundo tem
rotina todo mundo tem trabalho todo
mundo tem desculpas
isso acaba sendo desculpa é algo que
todo mundo faz sejam diferentes
gasta em sua energia com coisas que
realmente importam para vocês e não com
coisas que dizem pra vocês são
importantes
então façam a sua lista
quantas pessoas vocês conhecem e que têm
sucesso
pergunto aposto que a grande maioria de
vocês deve estar pensando ainda [ __ ] eu
conheço tem sucesso é aquela pessoa que
você olha pra ela você vê que ela é
realizada com aquilo que ela faz
talvez vocês tenham conseguido lembrar
de uma ou duas
talvez muito provavelmente quase ninguém
porque porque a grande maioria dessas
pessoas que têm sucesso que são a
minoria da população porque elas não
usam desculpas
elas não falam das desculpas essas
pessoas fazem passagem existem dois
grandes grupos de pessoas no mundo os
fãs
dores e os fazedores as pessoas de
sucesso estão no grupo dos fazedores e
estes fazedores eles têm quase que uma
força divina uma luz que vem do céu e
que mostra para eles exatamente quando o
que eles vão conseguir fazer o que eles
têm que fazer para chegar no sucesso
deles porque eles também têm rotina e
também trabalho também tem família
também em casa também tem louça para
lavar
só que esses caras são iluminados porque
eles têm esse dom de perceber exatamente
quando como e de que forma eles vão ter
que começar a agir para transformar a
vida deles para deixarem de serem
faladores que dão desculpas e se
tornarem fazedores neste momento vou
dizer pra vocês agora qualquer se resume
a uma única palavra momento certo onde
você vai ter dinheiro extra tempo extra
espaço extra tudo extra tudo sobrando
pra que vocês consigam fazer o que vocês
querem começar a correr atrás do sonho
de vocês esse momento se chama nunca
nunca haverá recurso extra
não esperem por recurso extra não espere
um momento perfeito comecem a fazer vai
dar errado com o momento perfeito não
vai dar errado pra cá sem o sucesso é de
fracasso em fracasso sem perder o
entusiasmo então fracassem bem a cara a
tapa se ponham a riscos coloquem a prova
r mas comecem sejam fazedores comecem a
fazer o que você tem que fazer para que
você chegue no sucesso de vocês
isso não vai ser do dia pra noite não eu
digo pra vocês outra coisa vida mas é
feita na sua maior parte de tristezas ao
invés de alegrias
sim é assim como o é é assim que o mundo
funciona você bota a cara na rua todo
mundo tem que botar pra baixo todo mundo
diz que não todo mundo acompanhou na sua
cara eu levei muito de marcar não recebi
muito não muito não as pessoas olhavam
para mim e falava você é louco de querer
entrar no mercado financeiro de largar
seu emprego que eu trabalhava na área de
uti e foi para o mercado financeiro
você é louco as pessoas falavam e eu
olhava pra elas sabendo que eu já tinha
passado a noite do arroz em sal
sabendo que a minha vida mudou a partir
do momento que eu decidisse um fazedor
e eu olhava para aquela pessoa falar na
cara é mais um motivo para ir lá e fazer
porque o desafio
o fato de saber que era difícil e que eu
errar e trazer uma coisa eu sabia que eu
ia aprender e aprender de novo porque eu
errar de novo e eu ia aprender de novo
porque eu errar de novo eu errei eu
fracassei e eu caí e levantei todas as
vezes
foi algo que eu vivi e eu não tive medo
porque eu sabia que toda vez que eu
errado eu aprendia nelson mandela
nelson mandela eu nunca perco diz nelson
mandela ou eu ganho ou eu aprendo eu
ganho ou aprender nunca perco e foi isso
que eu fui errando errando errando
muitas vezes e eu percebi uma coisa
fracasso de preparo com sucesso
quando você fracassa você aprende você
se torna melhor você se torna algo maior
e mais forte que derrubou e não te
derruba agora porque se o sucesso caiu
no seu colo do dia pra noite ele
simplesmente escorre das suas mãos
porque você não está preparado para
lidar com sucesso
você não sabe como lidar com aquilo você
não tem preparo físico e emocional do
seu tempo não está organizado você não
tem preparo você não tá pronto o sucesso
embora então estejam preparados para
quando o sucesso bater na porta de vocês
não se deixe enganar
não se deixe enganar nunca vai ser
perfeito para o sucesso caiu no colo de
você tudo vai dar certo lindo
maravilhoso vai funcionar
r bem a cara a tapa fracassem
aprendam porque quando vocês estiverem
prontos o sucesso bater na porta de
vocês aí sim vocês vão falar entra entra
aqui daqui você não sai mais
tá então estejam preparados já a
terceira dica que eu dou pra vocês é que
se a vida feita mas de tristeza do que
alegrias então escolham as tristezas
certas você quer ver a tristeza de ter
um sonho de falar pô tá longe tem que
sair do trabalho tem que fazer outra
coisa tem que estudar tem que virar a
madrugada estudando em coisa que não vai
trazer nada agora você prefere ver a
tristeza de pé
assim nunca e por seu sonho
ou você prefere ver a tristeza de tomar
porrada de errar e levaram os elevados
na sua cara e no final consegui
quantas tristezas você vai viver para
chegar no seu sucesso
seu sucesso e agora é o meu sucesso de
agora é o que viver sem o relógio isso
isso é sucesso pra mim
o dia que eu puder viver sem relógio sem
preocupar com o tempo de 1 hora com o
dia da semana ou seja lá o que for
provavelmente eu vou tá no meu sucesso e
aí talvez eu tenha outros é seu sucesso
vai mudando
quantos mais sucessos você tem mais
sucesso você quer buscar sucesso uma
sucessão de fracassos
tá isso você tem exemplos gigantescos na
na internet e nos livros michael jordan
oprah winfrey steven spielberg que não
conhece esses nomes todos eles foram
rejeitados todos eles receberam não
todos eles receberam dedos na cara e
disseram não você não vai dar nada
você nunca vai chegar lá mas eles não
desistiram e foram pará cassando até
conseguir enxergar um sucesso tá então
pessoal coloquem o esforço de vocês
o tempo de vocês a energia de vocês o
que realmente importa pra que vocês
consigam chegar em que é o sucesso de
vocês e não tentem dar um passo maior
que a perna não ganhar quero ser
astronauta eu amanhã eu quero ser
astronauta senão não pô para o seu
sucesso hoje
hoje eu me virar com as minhas contas
depois o meu sucesso uma vez foi o que
foi eu me virar para arrumar o meu
computador durante essa caminhada toda
eu cheguei a ficar três meses
economizando dinheiro para conseguir
trocar fonte do meu computador isso que
eu ia trocar porque eu era técnico em
informática
se tivesse que pagar alguém para fazer
tava lascado né e e durante essa
situação onde eu já tive o primeiro
sucesso quero me sustentar
eu passei a perceber que eu ia pra outro
sucesso
quero que trocar a fonte no computador
tudo isso do meu emprego eu fui
conversar com o pessoal pediu um aumento
eles falaram não dá não pode tal a gente
te ajuda trocar fonte do seu computador
e eu falei 'não não quer ajuda
eu quero poder trocar eu mesmo com o meu
sucesso
e aí eu tive outra oportunidade de novo
emprego e neste novo emprego eu fui
tendo outros sucessos no meio de tantos
fracassos e aí começou a sobrar um
dinheirinho e foi nisso que eu conheci o
mercado financeiro foi assim de sucesso
em sucesso da equipe e conhecer o
mercado financeiro que foi quando sobrar
um dinheirinho e eu queria saber como
que eu investir um pouco mais pra
conseguir rentabilizar seguir e me
apaixonei pelo que estava fazendo ali
pelo mercado e eu fui estudar e aqui
hoje
então comecem com o sucesso pequeno um
passo de cada vez mais tenho o seu
sucesso porque a galera vou dizer uma
coisa eu sou muito novo ainda mas uma
coisa já aprende só se vive uma vez tá
no final das contas todo mundo vai para
o mesmo buraco na verdade então
aproveitem essa vida que vocês têm essa
única chance que você tem tem um livro
escrito por uma enfermeira australiana
chamada brasil é a escrever um livro
onde relata ou quando ela cuidava de
pacientes terminais a qual era o maior
arrependimento que essas pessoas têm uma
vida né e disparado o maior
arrependimento que era relatado pelas
pessoas no seu leito de morte era abre
aspas
eu queria ter vivido a vida do meu jeito
e não do jeito que as pessoas queriam
que vivesse então pelo amor de deus não
se tem chance para que você chegue no
final da vida de vocês vocês dêem uma
entrevista no leite no leito de morte de
vocês dizendo que vocês não viverão a
vida que vocês queriam viver
escolha uma tristeza certa não escolhi
uma tristeza errada porque se vocês
escolherem a tristeza errada vocês
perdem um entusiasmo com o sucesso e
fracasso para casa sem perder o
entusiasmo
portanto escolheram as tristezas certas
para que vocês vivam a vida do jeito que
vocês querem para que você chegue no
sucesso de vocês gradualmente
fracassando e aprendendo
eu nunca perco eu ganho o eu aprendo
obrigado
[Aplausos]